when I first came on to play Peter Quill
the Guardians of the Galaxy were like
you know this ragtag squad of nobody's
I turned in my first draft of the
screenplay and I was really afraid but I
felt good about it people didn't
understand why we were doing that space
movie with a tree and a raccoon I think
the Guardians are so imperfect their
paths are not squeaky clean this found
family putting trauma behind them to
become their best selves there's
something really special about that
[Music]
around
just like
it's all right like
find us all
for each and every one of us to live
within the Marvel Universe it's been
very very special everybody always comes
to work with the same level of
excitement since day one
[Applause]
we are very much committed to James
Vision he's a great captain
he really believes in this story
so much fun because there is so much
comedy in it and so much emotion being
on set with everyone knowing that
there's a finality to the whole
experience really made me very emotional
I mean we're a family they're all people
that I want to keep in my life to be
part of something that's just so
universally beloved it's special it's
hard to even put into words
it's been it's been a blast
are you ready
[Music]